[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I consider myself an artist and my
process for everything that I do is more
of an artistic process than an academic
or commercial process it's usually
involves a lot of chaos it usually
involves a lot of angst and somehow
someway something beautiful comes out at
the end of it and so I actually relate
quite well to two artists and performers
and I sort of feel a kindred spirit when
Jen and I go out for dinner we talk
about all kinds of things and very often
we talk about creativity what makes us
creative and the conversations that we
end up having are insightful for both of
us and the last time we went out for
dinner we said well this is unfair we
should really let others in on this and
so it's actually very exciting for me
you know I spend so much time talking to
business people they're nice but I you
know coming back and doing things with
artists is much more my home so it's
it's this is actually a joy for me to do
and so I think the goal of today I'm
sure I'll wax on but the goal of today
is I'm here for you to answer questions
we can talk about what creative process
is what it means to be an artist in
today's and day and age you know I have
gripes about some of it and and
hopefully we can all learn something and
be better off by the end of it so I'm
here to serve I'll tell you one I'll
just start off with one frustration I
have about the arts today I guess two
frustrations okay three three first I'll
share two frustrations one frustration
is the concept of patronage has gone
away
you know Beethoven and Mozart didn't pay
their own bills um somebody else saw
talent in them and somebody else paid
their bills yeah they did some teaching
but let's be honest that's not what paid
the bills and they had patrons who paid
their bills so that they would produce
and we have the symphonies and the
sonatas and the operas that we have from
them because others wanted to invest in
that that was the product that was the
return on that investment the ability to
contribute to to society to the arts
what I lament is that the arts have
unfortunately too much become business
where the investment is to get money
back you know rather than to produce
something that is so necessary and
beautiful beautiful that it actually
contributes to to society at large
I miss the concept of patronage and I
would love to bring something like that
back now I guess we have grants and
things it's not quite the same I
literally mean that an artist with
talent that others recognizes has talent
gets a salary that you don't work you
don't have a survival job your survival
job is the patronage I know I so that's
one lamentation the other the other one
is as I mentioned that that too much of
I'm okay with a portion of art being
business there's no problem with that
my concept my problem is is is it out of
balance has too much art become built
business you could say the same thing of
hospitals you could say the same thing
of universities where universities too
much have forgotten that their
responsibility is to educate students
not get donations right hospitals have
forgotten that their responsibility to
take take care of doctors and nurses and
staff so that the doctors and nurses and
staff can take care of the patients it's
not how much money can we bring in and
how many famous doctors can we brag
about somebody once told me recently
that they introduced me to a I think was
a heart surgeon or some sort of famous
surgeon and they said you know they rate
these surgeons on how many of their
patients died you know that's how they
keep track of who's the best and and he
said you're very lucky to meet a surgeon
here who has one of the lowest mortality
rates of all surgeons in his in his
field and I said oh I would never see
him and my friend said why not I said
because he passes on all the difficult
cases so we can make sure that his
patient
live and I can guarantee you that's what
happens I can guarantee you that some of
the most difficult cases the best
surgeons do not take for fear of
upsetting their metrics upsetting their
reputations right and unfortunately some
of the most important cases are being
passed up by some of the best surgeons
now of course that's not in general I
can guarantee you it's happening
the minute you start attaching numbers
to things like medical care or or
education or the arts necessarily or
each of those things will suffer its III
lament that universities advertise
themselves by bragging about the average
salary of their graduating students how
about the contribution to society of
their average student you know so so
anything that I can do to help ease the
way for you as you go on the journey as
an artist which is a and I hold you in
the same esteem that I hold the military
I have a really big soft spot in my
heart for people who undertake a career
of service where where sacrifice is a
large part of what you're expected to do
and few if any go into the business with
the expectation of getting rich right
and I think artists and and and military
are very very similar that it is if you
get it right if you get it right it is
an act of service it is an act of
service if you think it's about fame and
fortune I wish you nothing but luck but
that's also the difference maybe between
the film and a movie like one can stand
up as art and is hopefully entertaining
you want the other one is just
entertainment and hopefully is also
artistic so it's not a better or worse
thing but just it's about awareness of
the lifestyle and and career in the kind
of art artists journey that you want to
to go on that's my preamble
it's pretty great preamble what you just
said reminded me of a conversation we
had once and I'm gonna try to jog your
memory about what actually defines art
and you are using an example of
something that is in a gallery oh yeah
yeah okay okay so jog yeah yeah so so if
we can recognize things they must be
able we must be able to define them
right things that are recognizable are
definable and when people say art defies
definition then how do you know it's art
and so I challenged myself to define art
right to come up with a working
definition it's and it's not subjective
it has to be objective it's nothing to
do with art we like or don't like it's
to do with art and I and I and I think I
have a working definition I've been
testing it for years and so far it holds
up and it boils down to three things
there's three tests that something must
pass to be called art right and I'll
tell you what they are and then I'll go
through each of them one is intention
one is display and the last is reception
right two recept okay so and the test
that I gave myself right was things like
Robert Mapplethorpe okay Robert
Mapplethorpe took unbeli to unbelievably
beautifully shot pornography so what
makes it art and not pornography and
what makes you know something in a in a
pornographic magazine pornography and
not art so that's where I that was sort
of I put boundaries over here to make it
more difficult and so intention matters
intention is sometimes the intention of
the person who produces the work but not
always right so let's say that the
intention of let's say a pornographic
magazine the intention is not art the
intention is a masturbatory aid right
and so it immediately fails the first
test but what if a curator from the MoMA
decides to display
ten years worth of Playboy covers the
intention is now changed it wasn't the
intention of the photograph but now it
has been converted by the curator right
so it has intention not by the artist
per se not by the Creator but by the the
person who intends it to be art then is
display must be displayed in an area
that is consistent with the intention so
we're not displaying it in one of those
dine theaters we're displaying it in a
place of artistic reputation Museum of
Modern Art and then it must be received
as such people come inside interesting
and then come up with all kinds of
nonsense about what the interpretation
of what the meaning is right so like
Dada
if you know da tests what if you take a
peek like a piece of driftwood in nature
is just a piece of driftwood that's all
it is and if someone recognizes its
beauty and points wouldn't say isn't
that beautiful it's still just nature
it's not yet art but if somebody says
that it has qualities that I intend to
display separate from its natural
environment and I remove the piece of
driftwood I now have intention I then
display it in the museum and people come
and look at and say isn't that amazing
right so you have intention you have
display and you have reception which
means if you paint and you after every
painting you put the paintings under
your bed and they're never seen you're
not an artist you're just a painter
right though you may have intention
there's no display and there's no
reception if you're a poet and you sit
there and write the most fantastic poems
and show them to no one but your diary
you may have intention but there is
notice no display and there's no
reception it must pass all three for it
to become art you were simply a writer
of poems you were a poet but you're not
yet an artist right you can display it
in your own home that's fine you can
just hang it up or read your poems to
your friends totally fine and your
friends go that's an amazing poem great
can I read you my new poem yes you can
that's where it becomes art it's nothing
to do with the quality can be bad art
but it's it makes Jackson Pollock
defendable whether you like it or not it
makes Robert Mapplethorpe and by the way
if we take Mapplethorpe and put it in
a gay porn mag right it has now ceased
to be art it is now beautifully shot
pornography because the intention
display and reception has completely
changed so that's my working definition
of art lots of lots of gasping yes or if
there's intention display in reception
show so performance artists are somebody
who I mean I think to say the world is a
stage is a little too abstract
you know that's like the world is a
museum yeah yeah I mean too big too big
so so can human beings be works of art
if there is an intention display human
being is a work of art with somebody
displays that as a work of art and if
it's received as a work of art like
maybe the body's exhibition you could
argue you know or somebody who chooses
to do some avant-garde piece where they
sit in a chair for 12 hours you know in
the Whitney Museum which has been done
then sure why not but not all people at
all times not all poems at all times not
all art paintings at all times
somebody had to intend to for it to be
art for before it was displayed so I I
don't like I don't have a good argument
that it has to be in the order but it
seems to be a chronology to it first you
have to intend it or make it then you
have to show it to someone in somebody
has to go hmm you know so it's right I
think it's more I think it's more
practical than it is philosophical yes
mm-hmm so remember so the question was I
you know as an artist you you have
intention you have display but can I be
confident of the way it's received so
it's it's not about how that necessarily
that people receive it but is it a place
where it should be received as such so
if you put on a play in a theatre you
know it can be filled that people be
like this is an art right you can take
you know my grandfather that are looking
at Jackson Pollock you're like that's
not art it it's a balance thing you know
that's one person's I'm trying to remove
the subjective quality out of it
yeah yeah yes we can talk about other
things by the way besides my deafness
yeah so I think the part of it that I
the reason I added reception is because
to me art is like a gift you know if you
have capacity if you have talent if you
have grit and hard work and you want to
produce gifts are supposed to be given
so what's the point of giving a gift is
no one gets it right what's the point of
producing a symphony of no one gets to
hear it so I think reception is
important too to give the art point
meaning as opposed to point less you
know otherwise you're just decorating
your home now we could have a debate
whether I'm receiving it myself right so
we could definitely debate that but but
I I think it I think and maybe this is
just the romantic in me it has to be
enjoyed and and maybe one one one person
is fine
maybe if you hang it in your own home
and it's just for you that's fine too
but but I think art has to be enjoyed
otherwise what's the point you know
otherwise it's just therapy you know I'm
just painting for therapy and we all do
things like that you know our art order
has to have another human being involved
to me art is about a relationship right
you you can't call yourself a romantic
or somebody who chooses
to love another if if nobody ever feels
your love you know it's I think I think
art is is is it's a type of language
right
I know people who are the world's worst
communicators when it comes to their
emotions when you asked when you have a
conversation with them I've dated some
of them but given the opportunity to
write it's magical and the feelings pour
out on the page in an eloquence like
I've never seen and as everyone here
knows great art in some way shape or
form is always personal or semi
autobiographical right it's too hard to
write pure fiction you know we and we we
put ourselves in it because it gives it
a sense of reality in it and it's what
makes us passionate for the subject that
we're tackling I know dancers who you
know you meet them and they're like this
but as soon as they start dancing you
realize there's it's all there so so art
is language and if no one hears you know
does a treat if a tree falls in the
woods you know if no one hears what
you're saying is that we're saying
anything they're just false so what's
the point of writing a play that never
gets shown is just a thought you know
it's just an intention so yeah no I
think it must be sure that's it's the
it's it's one of the ways in which
people communicate language is obviously
the primary one in beautiful language is
art several years ago I was at the
National young Arts Foundation working
with I was working specifically with
theater artists but they are an
organization that I've talked to you
about before they have artists and the
literary arts the Performing Arts the
visual arts everything under an artistic
umbrella is represented in there the
best and the brightest of the next
generation of artists so the absolute
genius artist bill T Jones came down to
do an interdisciplinary workshop so we
had kids of every single artistic
discipline represented and he opened by
saying
if you are a creative artist raise your
hand so of course all hands went up and
then he said if you are a dancer a
singer an actor director put your hands
down and you could kind of feel the room
go like what the heck is going on here
and then he says you your hand should be
up if you are a poet if you are a
filmmaker if you're a choreographer a
composer a playwright a painter now
raise your hand if you're an
interpretive artists and dancers raise
your hand
singers raise your hand actors raise
your hand instrumentalists vocalists and
you can kind of feel this aha moment
happen so that's really the question I
have for you is when you are an
interpretive artist as most people in
this room are not sure about you guys at
home but in this room we've got mostly
people who interpret to someone else's
work so when you're looking for
opportunities to find collaborators
someone whose work that you are going to
help bring to life do you have any
thoughts about yeah about what that
relationship is like and how to do it in
a meaningful way yeah so I went to see a
play with a friend of mine who is an
actor and the play was awful I mean a
train wreck the script was awful the
directing was awful I mean it was an
absolute train wreck and those sort of
the applause was kind of like you know
except for the parents they loved it
and I said to my friend I feel sorry for
them I feel sorry for the actors that
had to be poorly directed with this poor
script you know do that and I said just
do they know she says of course they
know and she said but do not feel sorry
for them because as actors it is their
responsibility despite the poor
directing and despite the poor script to
still bring something of themselves to
bear something personal that we should
be able to say what a bad script what
poor directing but my goodness what a
performance right and so I was told not
to feel sorry for actors in bad plays
so the question does now the question
you asked was about collaboration right
should any of those actors have taken
the part now of course if you're gonna
take a part because you need an extra
cash
a little extra cash or you want to get
little extra practice then you have to
do so I think knowing I'm doing this for
the money or I'm doing this just to keep
keep my skills sharp but I'm under no
illusion that this is something that I
connect with but I'm gonna do the best
that I can and then don't lie to
yourself you know the other problem is
don't do that too often because that'll
just destroy any passion that you have
for your medium right and I think and
we've talked about this which is which
is any artist any person but especially
artists have to know they're why you
have to know why you're showing up in
the first place and you have to be able
to talk about it because if you talk
about it things happen people go I like
you right now you may not get the part
but you're more likely to find people
who want to work with you even if you're
not the most talented one who auditioned
this is my career by the way right when
I learned to talk about what I believed
I didn't talk about the things I've done
I didn't talk about the parts I've had
or the shows I've been in or who trained
me where the schools I went to resume
resume resume I started I learned to
talk about what I believed and some
people thought it was cheesy they didn't
call me back
good and some people went that's great
and I was not the most talented not the
most experienced not the best at my
field but because they stood for or
believed in what I stood for they wanted
to work with me they would rather work
with someone who understood them who got
them more than somebody who would just
take orders and do exactly what they
wanted regardless of facility right now
you have to have some facility of course
you know there has to be some level of
talent we're not talking about you know
all why and know what you know you're
gonna you got a
you gotta bring the goods as well but
you don't assess enough to be the best
great producers great directors we know
what they stand for
we're drawn to their work you can throw
out the name of the director I love
their work well their last three movies
sucked yeah that's okay you know you
know he's like we all have our like I
love you no Goomer del Toro just love
how I don't like all his movies I think
some of them are not that good I think
some of them are brilliant but I like
the way he views the world I want to see
it when it comes out and the fact is
because I know what he stands for and I
know how he sees the world I'm very
patient with the fact that he doesn't
always get it right right so so I'm a
huge modern dance lover like that's the
thing I love and I don't go to the Joyce
anymore
because everything that they have on
their stage is good it's good everything
is safe to me they put things on their
stage that that's good they sell tickets
nothing's bad and nothing's great it's
all good I don't go anymore
I go to BAM a lot I have seen things
that have profoundly changed my view of
the world and I have walked out of more
things at BAM
literally I'm like I'm done and my
friends like like we can I have walked
outs out of so many things at Bam and
yet I continued to go and continue to go
and I continue to go because I know what
they stand for that's my preference I'm
not saying it's right or wrong I'm
saying that's my preference that I would
rather take the risk of walking out
knowing that I might get moved in a way
that I've never experienced before more
than just go and have a nice night out
and see something that I know is good
right and I think that goes for our
careers as well you know which is if you
choose to be the kind of artist that
stands for something that you want to be
yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do you will get
fewer parts you will the parts you get
we'll move you in a way that most
artists will not get moved or you can
bend and manipulate yourself a little
bit and sort of be a little bit more of
what they want and play their role and
even though you don't really buy into it
it's a part and I want to be an actor I
want to be a performer I'm gonna I'm
gonna do what they want you will
absolutely get more parts without a
doubt you will met you will can arguably
have a better career but will you'll be
profoundly moved as an artist
the odds are lower it's not I kind of
say never it's just the odds are lower
it's not better or worse it is simply
the decision on how you choose to manage
or lead your own career both are
acceptable right one means you get to
use your facility a lot one means you
get to work a lot one means you might be
able to do only your art and actually
make a living one means that you're
gonna be meeting a lot of people and the
odds are that you will connect with
somebody at some point or you choose
this route which is much more difficult
and is fraught with much more risk and
much more struggle but you become known
for the thing that you are and it's a
choice and I think the the the mistake
that most artists that I mean especially
performing artists were this this
constant audition machine right I think
they try and play both and I don't think
you can be yourself and then also play
the part that they want you to play I
don't think you can I think that's
impossible I think that's where the
stress lies where you think you can play
both sides of the coin I think that's
where the that's where it becomes
depressing and I think that's where it
sucks the soul out when you when you
trick yourself to think that you can
have both because you can't it doesn't
exist on any planet you just got to make
a choice now you can make a choice half
way you can change directions but but
but there has to be a
has chosen and you you find confidence
in that path it may be difficult but it
doesn't suck the soul out of it you know
it doesn't become depressing it just
becomes difficult and that's okay
difficult is fine but I think you have
to make a choice and the kind of career
you want and again it's not good or bad
right or wrong
there's simply choices like there's
nothing wrong with choice there's
nothing wrong with Joyce Joyce sells a
lot of tickets there's nothing wrong
with it it's just a choice to live on
these extremes versus VX the extremes
this is very balanced this is very
balanced and it's like entrepreneurs
versus people who get jobs and come in
corporations like there's no right or
wrong or good or bad you know
entrepreneurs experience highs that
people in a job will never experience
they also experience lows that people in
a job will never experience people in
companies who take jobs with stability
and your highs are not that high but
your loans are not that low you know
they're both balanced but the point is
you can't have one without the other you
can't have this you can only have this
you can't choose to want this and this
it just doesn't work that way you get
this where you get this since the same
thing was I'm talking about here you can
have this as a creative career you can
have this as a creative career and then
you prepare yourself for four you know
it's like people with curly hair when
straight hair and people don't want
curly hair it's the same thing these
people will complain
these people will always complain that
why can't I ever get that and these
people complain I can never get a job
you're gonna be stressed no matter what
focus on the thing that you're getting
because that's the choice you made right
I dress much rather you focus the thing
you you you or you were pursuing right
if everything you're missing and so this
idea of affirmative thinking positive
thinking is essential for all people but
I think it's especially essential for
artists and there's a very very simple
biological reason for it which is the
human brain cannot comprehend the
negative it is incapable yes it's true
I'll give you an example
okay no no I'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
I'll prove it I'll prove it
okay the human brain cannot comprehend
the negative you ready don't think of an
elephant you can't you can't tell the
human brain not to do something right
and so what happens is we very often
reinforce things when we put things in
the negative right I can't get apart I
can't get apart I can't get apart right
or I can't do this versus I'm gonna keep
doing this I'm gonna keep doing this I'm
gonna keep doing this right and and it's
such a huge thing to convert things into
the affirmative you're supposed to do
with children as well we're supposed to
say instead of saying to children don't
eat on the couch we're supposed to say
eat at the table right we tell people
what we want them to do not what them
what we don't want to do pilots know
this right it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle because what they're doing is
focusing on the obstacle skiers notice
if if you ever seen skiers go through
trees do you know how they do that it's
very easy it's actually surprisingly
easy if you go through trees on skis you
go don't hit a tree don't hit a tree
don't hit a tree guess what you're
watching you're only looking at trees
all you're doing is seeing trees you
don't understand how anyone can ski with
all these trees right as opposed to
follow the snow follow the path follow
the path the only thing you see is the
path skiers know this if you say don't
hit a tree you'll hit a tree you won't
be able to find a path because all you
see is millions of trees if you say only
follow the path you actually don't see
any trees there's actually very sparse
trees there's plenty of paths it's
plenty of snow it's the same thing for
you if you focus on the obstacles all
you will see as obstacles if you focus
on the path through the trees all you
will see is path through the trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career
it's literally perspective it's
literally perspective something that you
said to me about actors who are always
looking for the next job are always
playing this short game and I would love
for you to talk about that because the
concept of being in it for the long haul
is yep so important yes okay I'm so I'm
not gonna bore you with grit and stick
with it Ness it's a it's a it's a more
philosophical concept right I've become
very very interested in the idea of
playing in games that have no finish
lines right
some games have finish line's right
baseball football right
getting apart is the finish line you
audition there's a beginning middle and
end who's rehearsal and practice
there's showing up for the audition and
you either win or you lose and then it's
over it's over right that is finite but
one's career is infinite there's there's
no end it's like our lives are finite
but life is infinite people come and
people go but life continues right
theater actors come and actors go but
theater continues it's infinite you
don't win theatre you win a part but
what happens once you get the part the
the finite game is over
now you enter the infinite game you have
to be able to convert right and the
reason this is important and I've seen
this unfortunately so many times I have
a friend one of those people who's
furiously talented frustratingly
talented and we all hate her because she
would oversleep and miss auditions and
then the one she'd roll into she'd get
the part like we hate her right
that is her career and as a little girl
I think she was eight years old ten
years old she drew a picture of herself
with her name and says New York City
Rockettes and she drew a picture of the
Rockettes now all she wanted to do was
be on Broadway and become a Rockette she
became a Rockette
all she wanted to do was get to Broadway
and we all know people like this some of
you are here which is from a young age
all you wanted to do was get to Broadway
and then you get to Broadway and then
what you've devoted your entire life to
one finite goal and when you get there
the immediate response is depression
because I I spent 15 years of my life
for this one thing and I got it and now
I don't know what to do next like what a
get to Broadway again doesn't have the
same ambition
it doesn't have the same passion you
know you've devoted your from you know
you're from Fargo North Dakota and
that's all you wanted to do is get out
of Fargo and make it to Broadway and you
may eat it right it doesn't have the
same kind of passion and this is because
these are finite goals there's a lot of
studies that have been done with
athletes who have finite goals to become
the greatest X in the world right so
Andre Agassi was one of these one of
these athletes he wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived
guess what everyone in his life he would
he would view them through how do you
help me get to that everything was how
does this help me get to that everything
was a transaction to how do you help me
move to there and then you know what
happens he achieved that he became the
greatest tennis player in the world and
you know what happened immediately after
depression Michael Phelps set out to
become the most medaled Olympian in
history do you know what he achieved it
you're not happened immediately after
depression they spend their whole life
working for one goal though most will
never get it the few that do don't know
what to do next because their goals were
finite their goals were finite right and
so there are finite components to your
career but your career should be
infinite so yes of course you have to
win the finite game you have to get the
part but immediately when you get the
part
now you convert to infinite now you
convert to the reason why you wanted to
do this in the first place by the way
team athletics doesn't suffer the same
thing so when the team wins the Super
Bowl the team wins the Stanley Cup
there is no depression afterwards
because there was a team because they
knew it wasn't about in each of them and
as individuals is about the group that
had to work together there's
relationships as opposed to solo
individual and I think one of the
stupidest things that artists do is
think that they're in this alone or
worse try to do it alone you're you're
stupid
right how do you have a marriage in with
one person paying attention to the
marriage it takes two right how do you
do anything difficult in the world by
yourself you can't is the answer human
beings are just not smart enough and
just not strong enough we're just not we
don't even have the emotional fortitude
to do it this concept of courage and
sticking with it it's all [ __ ]
courage is an external thing right so I
have met people who literally have
courage what we would call courage they
have put their lives on the line they've
thrown themselves into harm's way in
order to save the life of someone else
they have done something that we would
consider mad that violates all tenets of
survive you knows that we're supposed to
do things to make to survive so that
someone else will survive current real
courage and I've talked to them and I
think always say why did you do it
you've got a wife you've got kids why
would you do that they all give me the
same answer every time because they
would have done it for me because
someone else would have done the same
for me
it is the absolute confidence that the
person to the left and the person to the
right will do the same for me that gives
them the courage to do amazing things it
is external they're the most the world's
most famous famous trapeze artist would
never try a brand new death-defying act
for the first time without a net that's
madness that's what relationships are
the net right the day's you've not sure
you can do it the day's you're beaten up
the days you're hard on yourself the
days you're depressed the days you
wonder why it's worth it simply having
someone in your life agos I believe in
you you got this I'm here we'll do it
together cry on my shoulder that's what
gives us the courage to go back the next
day it's not us it's not us
when you become a Marine
the recruits will sit on the floor of
their barracks and they will watch as
their drill instructor for the next 13
weeks takes the drill instructor oath
right in front of them right now this is
the person to be yelling in their face
for 13 weeks right and they hear that
drilling truck structure say I will
continue to believe in you even when you
stop believing in yourself that's what
gives them courage to Kate keep going
right if you think that you can do this
alone you cannot and I wish that artists
would be more supportive of each other
at auditions you will look at each other
like you're the enemies right like
you're gonna take my part right as
opposed to saying to somebody good luck
or you got this I believe in you you're
so good I hope you get it and have
genuine joy when they do I'm not talking
about strangers not talk about everybody
in the room I'm talking about people you
know I'm talking about your friends who
show up for the same audition I mean so
many people when somebody else gets a
part of the they don't deserve well
maybe they were one of those artists who
spoke about what they believe and they
happened to connect with the person in
the room and maybe they've had 13
failures before you and you get every
now and then you get every third one
they do deserve it sometimes it's
completely unfair I have a friend who
auditioned for cabaret she auditioned so
many times that they knew her they loved
her right and she went in one time she
told me the story how she went in one
time they go oh you're perfect you're
perfect the problem is we want a
brunette and you're a blonde seriously
that's why they threw her out because
they have no imagination she'll die her
hair never occurred to them she's a
blonde she didn't fit the image my point
is it's unfair it's unfair get over it
you know it's it's unfair right it's not
a meritocracy it's just not right it's
just not and so I think I think this
idea of relationships III wish artists
especially performing artists had
support groups for each other
III don't mean I mean not online not
over text I mean every last Thursday of
every month a group of there might be
ten or fifteen you of in the group and
whoever can show up you go out for
dinner or you meet at someone's house
you just talk sometimes you talk about
the business and sometimes you don't it
doesn't matter but every last Thursday
of every month this group of artists who
are all going through the same thing
meet let me tell you the power of that
and the importance of that and I'll give
you an extreme example so that you have
no excuse to say well it wouldn't work
for us I met a former marine recently
named Zack Zack reached out to us we're
not really sure why he's not really sure
why but he did and he wrote an email
that touched us and so I called Zack and
I cried with him on the phone and I
wanted to meet him I actually got to
meet him this week Zack left the Marine
Corps and suffered serious PTSD he
refused to call at PTSD because he was
only deployed once and to him PTSD is
actually a badge of honor you earn if
you deploy multiple multiple times so he
hadn't earned the right to say I have
PTSD in his mind this is what he said
and it was so bad and the depression was
so hard the nightmares were so awful
that Zack decided to kill himself the
way he decided to kill himself
was that he took his motorcycle out on
the highway and he chose a truck and he
was gonna Ram his motorcycle into the
back of the truck and so he
was going 150 miles an hour down the
highway and right as he was about to hit
the truck for some weird reason the
truck changed lanes and he just went
right past it a completely different
time he decided to try again and you
know when when a highway splits or
there's a bridge this is usually a some
sort of concrete bollard you know Zack
decided to ram his motorcycle into the
concrete bollard he was upgrading his
strategy because it can't move he he was
hard on the throttle driving straight
towards a concrete bollard nobody's
exactly sure what happened or why it
happened but his back tire skidded on
dirt and it pushed him out of the way
didn't die so he tried again he decided
this time to ride his bike into oncoming
traffic so on the highway one night he
drove into oncoming traffic turn the
lights off his motorcycle and drove
trying to hit a car and all the cars
kept honking and driving around him he
didn't die he tried a fourth time and he
wouldn't tell us that story but it
didn't work and so he realized he
probably has to keep living and he
realized what he was missing was people
who get him and he met a soldier who
says I know what you're going through
come and work with me and Zack now has
devoted his life to helping other
Marines who are struggling people who
they feel alone and they feel that
nobody gets them they can ask for help
and there's plenty of support groups and
people and friends and sisters and
brothers who want to love them and hold
them but they have no idea what they
went through and so it's Marines helping
Marines
it's soldiers helping soldiers its
sailors helping sailors it's Airmen
helping airmen they don't even let
Airmen help Marines Marines help Marines
soldiers help soldiers sailors help
sailors and airmen help Erman somebody
who totally understands what you've gone
through and says I'll be there for you
so when they say you've got to go see a
shrink
I'm not seeing a shrink like dude I was
there I know exactly what you're going
through
telling you gotta see one they will look
after you and then they'll introduce you
to a psychologist who was a marine not
just some random psychologist or some
random doctor they keep it in the family
right and he's fantastic
and he's happy and he has purpose and I
mean what an amazing human being we got
to meet you know he's such a good guy
so if it works for them artists need to
help artists actors need to help actors
dancers need to help dancers singers
need to help singers triple threats need
to help triple threats you got it you
got to create community because your
friends don't know the world you live in
they don't know they're like you live
they can't relate they're
well-intentioned they just don't
understand you have to help each other
genuinely form a group of people who
love each other just go do think good
bowling together it doesn't matter what
you do but you've got to have community
you guys have very weak community and
it's most evident when you're waiting
I've gone I've gone just out of
curiosity I went and hung out I do
things like this I went I because I hear
you guys talking about it I want to see
was all about so I went by a new open I
went to one of those places that have
all the auditions and I just went and
hung out I wouldn't just hung out and it
was awful
he was I hated every second of it I
wasn't even auditioning and I didn't
want to be there I could feel the
tension I could see the daggers I could
feel the hatred I could feel the
jealousy I could feel the insecurity I
could see it and it was awful and I
hated every second and I didn't see
anybody and people knew each other
people like hey you know people in which
I didn't see anybody offer support to
anybody somebody practicing their lines
and somebody was just hanging around
nobody said let me help you I didn't see
any of them it was gross so so the
question was about visualization and and
while watching the Olympics you're
watching some of these these super high
performers and some of them talked about
visualizing this one athlete said I'm
uncomfortable visualizing right does
that what happened you're saying it's in
comes oh oh that's a different situation
all together so you're uncomfortable
visualizing success
[Music]
so there's finite success and then
they're staying in the game they're
different finite success and you have to
play finite games within the infinite
you have to write and there as long as
there's a beginning middle and end
that's a finite game and we all have to
agree on what the rules of the game are
we all agree that once the parts are
given out the game is over and everybody
agrees to that that's how we know it's
the end but there nobody knows what the
end after that is because we haven't
agreed upon it or nobody's even agreed
upon what success is is it money
is it number of parts landed is it the
size of the part you get is it being on
the front or being in the back like is
it better to be the lead and a small
play or in the chorus of a big one like
I don't know right the point is we
haven't agreed and we haven't agreed on
the timeframe well you have to be able
to land a part in four years otherwise
you're a failure or you're a success
like we haven't agreed that's the
infinite part of it right there are
finite components within but that's the
infinite part of it so the the the you
have to get comfortable visualizing I
hate to tell you but it has to be on
your own terms right
and it's the difference between seeing
in the trees and seeing the path is if
you're saying I'm uncomfortable seeing
success what you're saying is I'd rather
look at trees and here's the good news
you'll hit them
right like there's a narrative in your
head and that narrative has to change
because you will fulfill your own
narrative right I'll tell you a funny
story that makes my point in a secure
his way but it's a funny story so I
wanted to prove that all marketing was
the same thing no matter what you were
selling it was always the same thing
right and good marketing talked about
the buyer and bad marketing talked about
the seller makes sense I versus you
right so to illustrate my point I wanted
to prove that what the homeless do and
what Microsoft does is the same thing so
if you think about what the homeless do
there is advertising they sit there with
a little sign that says I'm homeless I'm
hungry I got six kids I'm a veteran like
whatever whatever whatever trying to
appeal to everybody that's called a
little billboard right Microsoft has a
billboard that says more memory bigger
screen all the rest of it right more RAM
or ROM right and what the homeless are
selling is goodwill so if you walk past
a homeless person you put money in their
cup you feel good if you give them
nothing you either feel nothing or feel
bad you paid for that feeling there's an
exchange of consideration I sold you
goodwill you paid for it you got it
right they're selling goodwill that's
what they're doing is selling the
feeling of goodwill so I found a
homeless person who was willing to help
me and her her sign was pretty typical
and I found out that she makes between
twenty and thirty dollars a day selling
goodwill and she works in 8 to 10-hour
day right $30 is considered a good day
right selling goodwill like I said her
sign was pretty typical so I asked her
if I could change her sign we did and
the sign that I gave her she made $40 in
two hours the sign that I gave her said
if you only give once a month please
think of me next time it wasn't about
the seller it was about the giver
what are the reasons people say they
don't give how do I know that they're
genuine I can't give to everyone so I
simply answer the questions if you only
give once a month please think of me
next time I know you can't give to
everybody I'm legit
that's all right now here's the point I
was gonna make she could have made $150
that day but after she made her $40 in
two hours she left because one of the
reasons she's homeless or we could we
couldn't surmise that one of the reason
she's homeless is she's decided that she
needs 20 or 30 dollars to live per day
so once she had it she moved on
that's a narrative it's a narrative
right so she'll stay there because she
didn't sit longer it's a narrative so
there's a wonderful little trick you can
use with your narrative right just add
the word yet at the end okay I'll never
get I'm not famous yet not that talented
yet I'm so bad I'm not good at auditions
like I need to get better any like I
suck at auditions for now right you can
just add a couple of words of hope or
opportunity or the potential for future
or some sort of infinite component that
will profoundly change your narrative we
all get hard on ourselves we all bleed
ourselves up and by the way in your
community when you start going out every
last Thursday of every month right and
somebody says I suck at this one of you
will say for now you'll you'll you'll
correct them I'll never make it yeah
just you don't have to yell at them
screaming like no you got to be positive
just just just throw in a word at the
end of the sentence for them so what you
have is a narrative so I'll give you one
more Olympic story I was also watching
the Olympics and this is what I mean I
realized this when I was watching the
London Olympics so couple Olympics ago
and I was annoyed by how all the
journalists asked all the athletes the
same stupid question literally everyone
were you nervous or are you nervous
whether it was before or after the event
every single time and every single time
all the athletes gave the exact same
answer
no as excited no I'm excited
every single time these elite athletes
had learned to interpret body stimulus
what is what are the signs of
nervousness your heart races you
visualize the future you clamp your
hands get clammy what's this what did
the stimulus for excitement your heart
races you visualize the future your
hands get clammy they had learned to
interpret what their buddy was telling
them not as nerves but as excitement and
the reason the journalists said were you
nervous is because they would be nervous
athletes would never say that to each
other they say that was exciting so I
tried I did a little test on myself
right I'm on a plane we start hitting
some really bad turbulence I go and then
I say to myself literally out loud this
is exciting and I was fine and I was
fine so I do it a lot now when I find
myself getting nervous I say to myself
this is so exciting and I'll explain the
reason to myself why so like an actor
you don't get nervous when you're going
to stage anymore
but occasionally you do so I get to go
on stage a lot and I don't really get
nervous much anymore but I was going to
present to 3000 Chiefs of Police right
in the middle of all this police
brutality hullabaloo and I got really
nervous because the stakes are really
high you know and I was literally
getting nervous backstage and I said to
myself this is so exciting I have an
opportunity to talk to a group of people
who can actually affect change in this
country this is really exciting now I
could have said the same thing I'm so
nervous
I'm about to talk to people who could
but the interpretation was excitement
just changed the narrative it works
brilliantly well I should give shorter
answers
we got a lot of questions before the
event about the relationship of an
artist to time and I you are someone who
is currently working under a deadline so
you can relate how when you are a person
who wants to create something and then
someone says great please create this
for me it's due on such-and-such a day
can you just talk about what that
relationship is like and how you manage
it I think some people are better at it
and some people are worse at I don't
think there's a universal answer for
this one you know I really admire
artists anybody that have discipline you
know so I know writers people ask me
what's your writing process because you
know do good because some writers treat
it like a job they write from 9:00 to
5:00 some artists treated as a goal and
where my 2500 words stay even if what I
write is crap right I do neither of
those things but it just doesn't work
for me I've tried it just doesn't work
my process is days of guilt and
self-loathing punctuated by hours of
sheer brilliance and I don't know when
there's hours and I don't know when
there's hours strike that's my process I
think the the relationship with with
time is you know it's like you know who
helped me on this and I can I can
empathize I can relate because of my
sophomore work you know because we spend
somebody asked me how long did it take
you to write start with Y which is my
first book and my answer was every day
of my life up until that day right the
problem is with your second work it's
like okay you have a year
but it took me every day of my life up
until that day to write the first one I
am not sure I can do it in a year and
people would always ask me you know I
think they were being they're trying to
be helpful but they would say things to
me like how are you going to do a second
TED talk as famous as the first one how
are you gonna write a second book as
good as the first one it's like thank
you thank you thank you thank you and it
was actually Elizabeth Gilbert's
TED talk that helped me she gave this
wonderful TED talk where she talked
about the concept of genius right where
prior to the I think was the Renaissance
probably was the Renaissance prior to
the Renaissance the or maybe probably
just doing the Renaissance the the
concept of genius was a daemon that
lived in the walls so if somebody
produced a marvelous work we would say
of them he had his genius his genius was
with him and if there was a flop they
would say she didn't have her genius her
genius wasn't there right so you could
never take full credit for your success
but you never had to beat yourself up so
much if you had a failure either and
somewhere along the line the genius that
you had became the genius that you are
she's a genius and for their for their
profound work that they produced and now
you have to live up to that and the
stress of living up to being a genius
because the one thing that you did that
none of us really know how we did it
because it was largely accidental even
though we take all the credit is the
stress is overwhelming the stress is
overwhelming and then you add deadlines
and the rest of it so I thank goodness
learn that lesson before I started my
second work and was at complete peace
with the fact that I had an inspiration
not that I was inspired or I am inspired
when I produced my first work
and was totally comfortable that I would
not produce a second work as good as the
first I
I removed the comparison and my only
goal was to produce as good a work as
that work could be irrespective of the
other work I wasn't trying to make this
work
better than that work I wasn't trying to
make this work as good as that work I
was trying to make this work the best
work it could be by its own standards
and its own metrics in fact the
techniques that I used to write the
first one I had completely different
techniques to write the second one all
the things that I relied on that helped
me stay productive and the first thing
they didn't even work in the second one
so I had to invent entirely new systems
to help me produce be productive in the
second one it literally was an entirely
different experience
with zero stress of comparison so I
think time is the same thing by the way
my first book was exactly on time I
literally handed my manuscript in on the
day apparently that's a big deal
apparently nobody does that I didn't
know that was my first book nobody told
me that nobody really hands it in on
time but I did literally on the day my
second book was a year late because I
had to write a good book based on its
own standards and I couldn't do it in
the timeframe now I'm the first to admit
I'm the first to admit that when you
write one book that sells exceptionally
well the publisher is much more patient
with the second one
I get that Susan Cain took six years to
write the book quiet it's her first book
six years right she's working on another
book it's probably gonna take her six
years she knows that she's okay with
that but like I said before I'm gonna
refer back to the answer I gave before
remember I said there's two ways to
manage a career you stand for what you
stand for and people either buy into her
don't it's much harder you're gonna get
fewer parts but my goodness my goodness
when you get them or you bend in shape
and you play by their rules the same
goes for this right when you say to
somebody I will work I will produce a
really good piece of work but the odds
are pretty high I'm gonna miss the
deadline if they are deadline-driven
you won't get the you won't get the job
but you feel like I'm gonna do it on the
deadline no matter what because I want
this job you'll produce something I have
no doubt it made me really good but
Susan went in very openly and said I
can't do it in a year I'm not going to
do it in a year there's there's no
insecurity I'm not gonna do it in a year
you'll have the book when I'm done with
it
hopefully it will be a few years but
you'll get it when it's done and they
went well okay
that's my point they bought into her not
the deadline right not better or worse
there's not better where some publishers
can afford that and some publishers just
you need to produce books and they
understand that sometimes they put [ __ ]
out onto the marketplace but hey look at
how many books we got on the market
they're playing a numbers game it's a
different business model but Susan made
the decision to to be that kind of
writer assuming that I meet my deadline
it'll be out in October amazingly I
think this is so funny about modern book
selling you can actually buy my book on
Amazon it's called the infinite game and
I haven't even finished writing it
anything that's so fantastically funny
but yes you can buy it it is it's not
even the right cover but it's a cover
[Laughter]
yes yeah those are behind you there was
a question yes yeah
yeah yeah cuz you know what they did
wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so the question was the question was so
she's a singer-songwriter but you still
perform other people's works and you
have frustration sometimes when you
perform other people's works because you
could do it better you would have done
it differently right and I think I think
to do both things you have to be able to
separate them right which is you you
have to be able to say I'm a creator and
I'm a Terp and I'm an interpreter and
you create when it's time to create new
interpret it's time to interpret it's
unfair to you but it's also unfair to
the other creator for you to come in and
judge their work based on your creative
standards just as when you give your
creations to someone else to perform you
don't need them or want them to judge
your work if you don't like the work
they don't sing it so and again you may
have two parallel paths which is I'm
gonna be this kind of artist for my
creation of them being this kind of
artist for my interpretation but you
kind of I mean I mean
have at it
I mean have at it but yeah yeah and my
question is why do you want the Grammy
why do you want the Tony what happens
once you get the Grammy so you only want
one Grammy you're okay with one Grammy
you only want one Grammy just to say it
did it how many's how many's a ton ones
at four is at five is a ten who has the
most
how many Grammys what person got the
most do you want that you want more than
that
why okay okay so what point doesn't run
out just I'm just curious but how many
grams you have to win before you switch
I think that you will you I admire your
your passion and your gussto I do I love
it and you have that drive and I think
you'll be very surprised how how after
the first Grammy the insecurity starts
to set in that you never had prior okay
because because you you will get to the
point where you can no longer judge your
work based on those own merits for
yourself you now want everybody else to
judge your work for you because that's
really what a Grammy is
[Music]
don't compare it's where your talent
lies right Michael Sheehan malleable who
is he good though I mean really really
good right there were brilliant
brilliant artists sometimes we don't
know who they are like most people don't
know their names because they play so
many roles so differently gary oldman
valuable artist Wow
the best one of the best what's his name
Daniel day-lewis I mean have you ever
seen two parts look the same never one
of the best malleable artists I've ever
seen in my life
Robert DeNiro not Somalia ball great if
you like that it's like I said there's a
wonderful review I went to see I went to
see a Philip Glass opera and the review
read the review was great the review
said it's the same tune but if you like
that tune it's brilliant
not malleable right when when when art
sounds like itself that's that kind of
art when art can be anything it's a
different of art so don't for one second
think one is better or worse right there
are great artists who play themselves
every time and they're great artists who
play others every single time
what they want rather than what I am
well I think so I think whether you're
an interpretive artist or whether you're
a create you know your Creator I I think
you should always be showing up to be
yourself right it I mean this is the
horrible term authenticity
you know because you never want to be
what they want you want to bring your
own interpretation to the part and
hopefully they'll like it it's a
slightly different mental model no I
mean can you imagine you go on a date
and on your first date you say tell me
how you would like to meet to be I'm a
valuable artist I'm very comfortable
I like pleasing people I like people
being happy I want you to be happy so
I'm going to learn what you like and I'm
gonna do that right it's it's not a good
way to start a relationship right and I
think the same goes for any kind of
piece I I want you to bring yourself to
it because yourself is the only thing
that distinguishes you from all the
other performers because training is is
a commodity rehearsal as a commodity
right your resume is the commodity
everybody's got a couple of great
coaches in a couple of great parts and
everybody fudge did a couple you know so
if everything else is the commodity and
the only thing that distinguishes you
from somebody else is you then I would
stick with that it's probably the only
thing you're good at to which is
yourself your master yeah yeah
I mean it's the same in my business you
know there are people who are much
smarter than me much more disciplined
than me have much greater command of
like when I quote studies I can't
remember the studies I was like there
was a study they did a study you know
they who do all the studies you know and
I'll stand on the stage of Blake and
I'll fudge I'll like get the numbers
wrong I'll be like 80% is like 75% and
there's a friend of mine who's in the
same who does the similar work who knows
every study and be like so a Stanford
study in 1989 and they found out that
79.6%
and I was like and he and he thinks it
gives him more credibility he thinks you
have to be able to do that because it
gives credibility and it does I just
wish I could remember it because I can
write and it drives him up the wall that
I can't I'm like they did a study and
like something like this with like about
80% I think something like that should
go check yourselves and and it drives
him nuts but that's kind of just who I
am and I'm at peace with it you know
so what distinguishes me from him is not
that I'm trying to do I really should
remember the names of the studies and I
really should he was kind of you know
unless I wrote him down and I don't like
doing notes unless I put them in a
PowerPoint and I refused to do that so
so my style is a little more casual
little more relaxed I could get all the
data right if I put it up on a slide I'd
never get it wrong but I sacrifice the
accuracy for this that's my choice it's
not better or worse it's my choice right
side of the room left side a room is
showing you up just just saying all the
questions are coming from the left side
of the room
yes I think there's a couple of reasons
the question was when I talk about what
you do and why you do it
that the your inclination was that
artist is so in touch with their
feelings they inherently would
understand the why but what you've
learned is they don't is that okay
why is that I think there's a couple of
reasons I think one of the reasons is
goes back to community which is you
don't help each other you don't talk to
each other it doesn't come out and
because you don't get to have that depth
of conversation with somebody about this
kind of stuff what are you gonna do it
yourself you know like when we do why
discoveries for anybody is it's it's at
least a pair right we we strongly
recommend people do it with someone it's
better it works better so I think part
of that is community you've actually
though you may be in touch with your
feelings I don't think you've ever gone
to the depths you need to go to
understand what your why is which is a
conversation and somebody else listening
to you and saying I don't understand why
did you say this forcing you to go
deeper right that's number one and I
think number two is dare I say it
hubris a little bit of excessive pride I
do emotions for a living right and so
the result is is very generic stuff
because I've talked to plenty of artists
and asked them do you know your why and
they with great confidence say of course
I call my white horse and I say what is
it what really inspires me is I want to
entertain people like how many people
can tell me that what really inspires me
is that I can transport people away from
their stress to another world like that
is entirely accurate for the entire
discipline that's like an airline
telling me are why is to get
people to where they're going true but
not proprietary it's good for the
industry so you're right you've cleverly
designed the Y for all entertainment
right accurate just too broad and so
within all entertainment there's a
different Y for music there's a
different Y for acting there's different
Y for dancing is it NY performing it's a
different wife of creating Brazil is it
all in and then is a different way for
you and the questions that you want to
grapple with are are what about you what
you do is worth the suffering
entertaining people is worth suffering
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know everything
that you go for in survival jobs and
living in a tiny apartment with 12
roommates is worth is worth some banker
boy paying $400 for ticket to come see
you [ __ ] so you can escape his
stress for the day for two hours
[ __ ]
right what is worth what about what you
do is so worth the sacrifice I mean
you're gonna have that conversation by
yourself unlikely but maybe every last
Thursday of every month another way to
get to that answer is to find the times
in which you did this thing that you
fell in love with this thing it might
have been a commercial flop it might
have been the worst experience of your
life but for some reason this one
specific incident is one specific
experience exemplifies what I love not
like you know do you love your wife I
like her I like her no no do you love
your wife I like her a lot I told you I
like her a lot like it's a different
standard like them love okay didn't like
the show didn't like the whatever it is
you were doing
you loved it find those I'll give you an
example so I did some work with the
Disney Imagineer
the Disney Imagineers are the ones
responsible for everything physical that
Disney makes the boats the parades the
shows the rides the parks the only thing
they don't touch is merchandising and
the films but everything else is the
Imagineers they're incredible
and I went to talk to the Imagineers
about this concept of why and I decided
a spontaneously to demonstrate it to do
an example and I picked a random person
in the audience one of the Imagineers I
picked an older guy because I figured he
was more seen you had been around for a
while and what I didn't realize I found
out afterwards the guy that I picked had
a nickname at the company his name was
ice chips because he was a cold bastard
[Music]
and people who worked for ice chips
didn't like working for his chips
because ice chips was hard to work for
hard on them and he and he drove them
hard as a cold bastard
I picked ice chips so I asked ice chips
can you tell me a specific story can you
tell me a specific story that helps me
understand what you loved about being a
Disney Imagineer and he didn't have to
think too long and he told me the story
he told took five or six minutes to tell
it was wonderful but here's the short
version he oversaw the design and build
of a brand new ride at Disneyland and on
its opening he decided to go to see it
run for the first time and he was
standing back and watching the parents
and the kids started to line up for the
ride and in the front of the line in
there was a guy in a wheelchair and his
daughter and he said everywhere in the
world what the world sees is a man in a
wheelchair and his daughter he said only
at Disneyland do we only see a father
and his daughter and it's the only place
that you can ever go where he will never
feel like he's
a wheelchair with his daughter he will
feel like he's just a father with his
daughter and if you know anybody who is
in a wheelchair who's ever gone to
Disneyland it is one of the best design
parks for handicapped disabled and not
only were we all crying but instantly
everybody understood why he was so hard
because to him those were the stakes
instantly everyone wanted to work for
him instantly
everyone wanted him to be hard on them
because they wanted to push to produce
that level of quality to have that kind
of impact in the life of another human
being
that's purpose but he had to go through
the process and nobody knew it until he
articulated it they they didn't like him
but once his Y was clear he didn't have
to change a thing he did not have to
change a thing
that's what Y provides it provides
context for who you are to your friends
to people you're auditioning to they
will understand your interpretation they
understand what you're bringing to the
part because you start with y and yes
you say it it takes a second it takes a
second where's your name what do you
what's your name where'd you come from
it's just throw it in there ignore the
question right I do it every single time
I go every meeting I have every meeting
that I call us and let me tell you why
I've called this meeting every meeting
that I have I let me go why why I wanted
to come to this meeting
and I'll ask it I want to know why you
took the meeting to please now you can't
do that yeah
but I will say before we get started
once you know why I took this meeting I
imagine a world that does not yet exist
I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe at work and
return home
at the end of the day and so I saw the
opportunity to have this meeting as
something that I'd hope will help me
advance that world my name is simon
Sinek and i'm from blood of love it
takes us what that took eight seconds
nobody's nobody's ever interrupted me
ever and say oh I just want your name or
I could say my why my why is to inspire
people to do the things that inspire
them so together each of us can change
our world for the better everything I do
is singularly devoted to that I'm hoping
that this affords me the opportunity to
bring that to life what does that six
seconds now you know exactly who I am
you know exactly what I'm gonna bring if
you don't want it you're not gonna hire
me if you do want to give me a chance
every single time it's never failed me
and I use it as my own filter to write
because it's always in my head so back
in the early days I often get accused
that I that I have the luxury of being
able to turn down things I've been
turning down things before I could
afford to I had no money in the bank
literally hand you know hand to mouth I
was living and yet I would turn down
business because it didn't feel right
didn't it wasn't right I chose a
different path I chose this path much
more difficult I mean true story guy
calls me up he says I got your name from
someone who hired you and spoke very
highly of you
thank you I've heard about your work
thank you
convince me why I should hire you my
answer don't what I'm not the right guy
for you which is what my polite was
saying you're not the right guy for me
I'm not right for this part I'm the
wrong one for this part I'm sorry
I'm not right I bowed out of things all
the time always saying I'm it's not me
which is true because I want I want this
the ones I loved were the people who
said you're onto something I don't think
it's perfect I don't think you have all
the answers I think there's some flaws
in what you're doing
but I think you're on to something with
a little grin like I want to work with
you they're buying my why they're ready
told me buy what's flawed but that takes
huge discipline and let me tell you it
does get very hard and you can
compromise now and then for practical
reasons I got it bills to pay I got it I
got it I'm an idealist
I know reality exists but you kind of do
too often like when you're getting into
shape like if you exercise a lot and you
can have chocolate cake knock yourself
out
you just kind of do too often every now
and then a little bit of out of balance
it's okay yes right side of the room
just saying just saying yes
personal emotions and to understand
better how the infinite and finite okay
so the first question was remind me how
do you deal with an evolving sense of
why self growth and all the rest of it
okay you only have one why okay you're
why was fully formed probably in your
mid to late teens it is the sum total of
who you are how you were raised
experiences you had when you were
younger it is who you are the rest of
your life simply offers you
opportunities to live in balance or out
of balance with that why the earlier you
learn it the more likely you can manage
the opportunities you say yes or no to
so that you remain in balance right so
your why has never changed ever
you only have one what you're talking
about is different things that you're
doing to bring your Y to life I've had a
few careers I had great passion for all
of them at various times and even this
journey that I'm on with this concept of
Y has changed multiple times what I'm
doing has evolved many times the what is
very malleable and flexible but the Y
that's underlying it's always been there
it's always been there so you only have
one Y okay and the self growth is be
coming to terms with it and making sure
that you're making decisions that keep
you in balance that's the growth that's
the good you get and that's an ongoing
process no one's perfect at it you get
better and better and better at it right
you can keep reinventing yourself as
long as you can it you can reinvent you
can reinvent it to yourself as long as
it's consistent with why you do what you
do yeah you can do different things as
long as it's consistent and you find
that that new thing actually does allow
you to to bring your Y to life that's
that's great
and the your second question was what
how the how the infinite game relates to
the why how and what yeah sure yeah yeah
okay so my my my work is
semi-autobiographical my work is about a
journey it's my journey it just so
happens there other human beings out
there on similar human journeys just so
happens thank goodness so why is where I
started why is about knowing why you do
what you do it's this higher sense of
purpose cause or belief and it's the
thing that attracts people to you and
attracts you to people right the problem
is what happens once you've been
attracted to all the people that people
are attracted to you that's when I wrote
leader Z last now that you got the
people what do you do with the people
how do you make an environment in which
people love and trust each other is that
them or is it the environment turns out
it's the environment get the environment
right you get trust and cooperation get
the environment wrong you get cynicism
paranoia mistrust and self-interest it's
not the people it's the environment okay
so now you got this amazing team and
everybody loves each other but the
problem is you work in reality and the
world doesn't care about your why and
the world doesn't care about your team
they only care about themselves and what
they get and what they want so how was
an idealist supposed to operate in
reality and that's where the the
construction of the finite infinite game
has helped me understand and manage how
I go through reality so I'm not just a
an idiot with his head in the clouds
I'm also an idiot with his feet on the
ground and that's what the that's what
it is so the concept of why there's five
things that you need to play the
infinite game right just cause
courageous leadership vulnerable team
worthy adversary and in a flexible
playbook right so the first one just
cause
that's the why but just cook you have to
have a why to play the infinite game
then courageous leadership you have the
courage to do it say yes and no two
things
say yes to difficult things where's my
friend with the visualization say yes
difficult things and say no to things
that you know were wrong even though
they may look good on paper we do that
with people all the time right and the
third thing Valle nerble team that's the
circle of safety that's leaders eat last
then you add in a worthy adversary okay
where the adversaries about respecting
the people in your industry your
competitors respecting them not hating
them because what you're worthy
adversaries do what those people in that
audition room do is they reveal to you
all your weaknesses that's why we get
insecure that's why we hate people we
hate the people we hate the people who
reveal to us our insecurities they make
us feel bad about ourselves right so
it's not them it's you right and that's
good because that's a worthy adversary
because we don't run our best times we
run around a track by ourselves that's
if you only went to auditions by
yourself you'd actually never improve
because you have nothing to judge
against we run our best times we run in
a race now if your entire goal is to
undermine the competitor of your entire
goals to beat your competition you can
shoot your competitor in the race and
you will get the part you will win the
race but you'll still be a slow runner
or or you lose the race and you learn
why they ran the RET why they won the
race you learn your weaknesses I'm bad
in the straightaway good it turns bad in
the straightaway I'm only gonna practice
the straightaway
I'm better at sprinting I'm no good at
distance whatever it is and you work
harder and harder because the only true
competitor in an infinite game is
yourself everyone else there is to
reveal your weaknesses to you so you can
find the areas in which you can improve
I'm susceptible to it there is there's
another author out there that I hate
I hate I hate him and when I look at my
my book ranking on Amazon I don't look
at anything else my book ranking and his
no one else just the two of us
and when mines up I'm like and when mine
when he's ahead of me and like doesn't
deserve it
now he's super smart he's super good at
what he does he's really compelling I
intellectually I know he's really good
but I hate him so we were invited to
speak on the same stage and the
interviewer said to us why don't you
guys introduce each other and he said
I'll go first
Simon so now I had to go first because
he was being funny I'm like funny here's
what I said to the audience I turned to
him in front of the audience and I said
you make me really insecure I said
because all of your strengths are all of
my weaknesses and he turned to me he
said funny I feel the same about you we
are now close friends we love each other
I love it when his book is doing better
than mine I love it when his careers on
fire I love it when people bring up his
name I'm proud of him and I want his
work out there because I came to terms
with the fact that it was never him
can you unpack the playbook oh the open
playbook the fourth one was the worthy
adversary and the flat one is the
flexible playbook of the open playbook
the flexible playbook means that the the
Just Cause is fixed but the path you
take to get there must be flexible so
going to my singer-songwriter friend in
the back the path you take is flexible
you can bring your cause to life in any
way you want it's the people who say I'm
only a singer and so they only take
singing parts and they close the
opportunity to do things that would
inspire them and inspire others and
force them to work really hard at
something that they're not already good
at because they haven't been practicing
for 20 years because they've got a fixed
path and the cause becomes malleable is
like through and they justify it as
opposed to saying my cause is fixed and
I'll take whatever path I need to take
to advance my why so I'm learned this
right I am NOT a public speaker but I do
a lot of public speaking I'm not an
author but I've written a bunch of books
I refuse to define myself by what I do
at the time that I did those things or
at the time that I choose to do those
things those are the things that I have
decided are good ways for me to advance
my message in my cause and if I stop
speaking publicly my self-identity is
totally fine like we all have friends
who are doctors and bankers and one
another and when they stop doing that
thing they literally they lose their
self-identity we wrapped too much of our
identity in what we do rather than
define ourselves as devoted to a cause
bigger than ourselves it was Martin
Luther King a public speaker or was he a
man devoted to a cause of course is
devoted to a cause I choose to live a
life devoted to a cause define myself by
none of those things to the point I'm
actually a bastard about it to the point
like when I blur books right they always
write it was the best book I ever read
right and then underneath it'll say
simon Sinek
and then this is how that you do for
other people
CEO blah blah blah best-selling author
blah blah blah right that's it the
credibility that's why they do it right
and imma bastard about it I make them
right this is the best book I ever read
simon Sinek optimist and author of
author always comes second optimist
comes first because if I stopped writing
books and still an optimist my identity
is wrapped into why I do what I do not
what I do
so that's what the open that's what the
flexible playbook means it means that
you're open to the fact that there may
be paths that are different to the one
that you're on and those paths if you
choose to take them may be extremely
difficult to do I could be one silly
example so Steve Jobs had a very clear
sense of purpose a very clear sense of
cause which is to give the individual
the power to stand up to big brother
right he loved that and he saw the
personal computer is the great way to do
that right that an individual could
compete against a corporation how cool
is that right and he's already a famous
CEO they've had success with the Apple
one they've had success with the Apple
two and their next product it's called
the Lisa right that's their next big
product now coincidentally at the same
time that they were developing the Lisa
Jobs in a bunch of the senior executives
went to visit Xerox and Xerox showed
them a new product that they invented
called the graphic user interface a new
technology and jobs as he's leaving
Xerox says to his guys we have to invest
in this this is way better than what
we're doing this is a leapfrog of what
we're doing people don't have to learn a
computer language they can just move a
mouse on the screen that means even more
people could take down the man we have
to invest in this graphic user interface
thing and his guy said Steve are you
crazy we've already invested millions of
dollars in countless man-hours in the
Lisa we can't walk away from it if we do
that we'll blow up our own company to
which jobs replies better we should blow
it up than someone else that decision
was the Macintosh a computer platform
that profoundly changes computing as we
know it the entire software of Windows
designed to mimic a Macintosh
that's a flexible playbook that's a man
with a fixed cause and an open path
which means you might have devoted
thousands of dollars and countless years
becoming X except that's better and
you're gonna have to learn a whole new
discipline as we've really hard work and
you're gonna walk away yeah if but it's
not random and it's not opportunistic
it's not because I think I can make more
money here it's because I found a better
path that will help me advance my cause
I technically we're done but I'll keep
going if you want we'll do a little more
I think should we take any questions
from Facebook or did that not work out
okay okay let's do a couple Facebook
uestions a if you if you guys need to
leave technically we're done and you
need to leave you can leave I won't be
offended oh I have to say goodbye to you
cuz you're going away for a week come
here no you have come here have a
wonderful wonderful holiday thanks so
much yeah if you need to go that's fine
I'll just keep going for those who want
to stay
okay so what are certain techniques we
can use to go back to our authentic
state when we what when we feel like we
can't show our authentic state who
there's a lot going on on that one well
we don't okay we how do we get back to
our authentic state we don't feel like
we can show so have you lost it so
authenticity and I don't like the word
is let's because nobody really knows
what it means so authentic what
authenticity means is that you say and
do the things you actually believe
that's it that's all it means so if
she's saying when you don't feel like
you can show it that means whether she's
choosing where she feels pressure to not
say and do the things she actually
believes right this is what she means by
being an authentic so though how do you
reclaim your authenticity well one the
easiest way I mean knowing your Y is an
advanced way let's be honest right
because you can do without knowing your
Y the best way to do it is I'll go back
to that sense of camaraderie and
friendship which is you have to have
someone in your corner who loves you who
knows you for who you are who loves you
for who you are and wants you to be who
you are and you need someone in your
corner who says you got this be yourself
right I love you so I think the the the
the thing to do is
Brene brown talks about this which is we
don't build trust by asking for we don't
build trust by offering help to others
we build trust by asking for help from
others
and so it takes a much more courage to
say somebody I need I need help versus
how can I help you and I think sometimes
we say how can I help you when what we
really mean is I need help and this is
my story
I lost my passion and I was in a dark
place and I was very inauthentic and I
was trying to portray a role that wasn't
me of successful entrepreneur when I was
a failing entrepreneur and a friend came
to me and said I'm worried about you
so she opened the door and thank
goodness I stepped through it and said I
need your help and I came clean and it
took a huge weight off my shoulders and
all the energy that I was using lying
hiding and faking which is what we're
doing when we're being inauthentic I
could now invest that energy and finding
solution the solution I found was this
thing called the Y so it was because of
a friend that my life was changed and
saved not because of me not because of
me my genius was in my friend so I don't
take any credit for it so it's the same
thing you know there's something I've
had the opportunity to spend a lot of
time with folks in the military and they
do things very differently to us I've
hugged more people in uniform that I
have in suits I've cried with more
people in uniform than I've cried with
in suits I've stood in audiences and
listened to officers give a briefing
that I've cried at I've never cried when
a CEO give a speech we have colleagues
and co-workers they have brothers and
sisters it is a different relationship
right and I remember I had a I had an
experience where I was on a stage
talking to a group of senior officers in
the Air Force and I told a very very
difficult story for the first time and I
choked up and I couldn't go I couldn't
go on you know you get to that point
where you know if you go on you're gonna
lose it so you just don't go on
and you just hold it you know you just
don't because you know if you say one
more word you you love her and so you
don't and in the private sector I know
what they do they say don't worry they
say take a minute right they that's what
they do in the private sector I heard
two words come from a general in the
audience
he said go on very different instruction
he didn't say take your time he didn't
say take a moment he didn't say compose
yourself
he said you're in a very very very safe
space here right
he said go on it's all I heard and so I
went on and I cried it was good
so what we need is when we hold back for
fear or concern that we're going to cry
or that we may accidentally reveal
ourselves
that instead of saying to somebody take
your time have a moment when you're
ready instead we say to them go on
that's stuck with me want to do another
Facebook question yeah if we go back to
my homeless example everybody's selling
something to somebody yeah so yeah sure
it's all the same right I think in the
retail industry if we try and link it
back to the arts there are like I'll put
it this way there is a refusal to
compete here's what I mean here's what I
mean any participant in any industry can
get lazy when there is little change in
how that industry operates and then when
there's a sudden change to how the
industry operates everybody gets angry
panics and points a finger I'll give you
an example okay I'll give you two
examples example number one taxi
companies around the world hate Buber
right now here's the reality the app
that calls a car not proprietary you can
call a taxi with it with an app right
paying with your phone not proprietary
any taxi can do that as well
the reason Ober is eating taxi companies
for lunch is because it's a better
product and the taxi companies around
the world could have a shitty product
because you're the only game in town and
we had no choice and now you have a
competitor and instead of competing
you're getting angry I would gladly take
more cabs than coal services if I got in
the cab and he said hi and it was clean
and I had a nice chat with him and he
wasn't on the phone and he wasn't
smoking and in all of these things and I
had some leg room I'd gladly gladly
gladly has nothing to do with the app
the paid mechanism has to do with the
fact that Juno and lyft are just better
is it just a better experience better
product is why I take them it costs a
dollar more whatever I'll pay for it
it's not even a price thing I have no
idea but she's were more expensive but
actually we never compared the same goes
for Starbucks right so there was a lot
of people hate Starbucks because they
put mom and pops out of business right
the reality is the complete opposite
that when Starbucks moves into a
neighborhood mom and pops coffee shops
actually do better for two reasons one
Starbucks attract more customers so
there's more people and the second
reason is there is a groundswell of
giving back to the local and so more
people go to the mom-and-pop right the
ones that go out of business the ones
that refuse to compete
I'll give you a real-life example this
goes back a few years a real life
example I'm lactose intolerant right so
I don't have milk in my coffee and there
was a time where it wasn't a foregone
conclusion that every coffee shop had
soy milk or almond milk or something so
I would always go into the mom-and-pop
that was across the street from
Starbucks always go to the mom-and-pop
and I'd say do you guys have any soy
milk and they go no but I like thank you
and I would walk
out those went out of business because I
went to Starbucks he's right I went to
Starbucks now had Starbucks moved in and
they went across the street and said
let's see what Starbucks has we should
offer soy milk maybe it's time for us to
replace this ripped couch that we've had
for 15 years because it's really nice
across there and it's really gross here
it's the ones who got angry and refused
to compete that went out of business I
think retail is the same everybody's
pointing fingers instead of saying we've
had it really good for a bunch of years
and the question is now what is our
competitor revealing about our own
weaknesses that we can learn to improve
because that's what competition does
competition reveals your weaknesses to
you and when you had no competition you
didn't know where you were weak this is
the problem with being the best at
anything because you don't know where
your your faults are and then somebody
undermines you because they can see your
faults before you can we'll do one more
Facebook question and then we'll do some
more in here and then we'll probably
should wind down how do you do how do
you stay inspired when doing all the
parts of your work that are tedious and
not inspiring not creative sorry how do
you stay inspired when when you're doing
all the parts of your work that are
tedious and not creative okay the answer
is do you know it's like raising
children okay having children is awful
don't try and convince me otherwise have
you seen what your apartment looks like
have you seen what your house looks like
your definition of dinner is eating
macaroni and cheese over the sink with a
plastic spoon right if you have a
backseat of a car it's destroyed
[Laughter]
you have kids that throw temper tantrums
and all you want to do is watch TV but
they don't want to go to bed that's your
life right you have to travel at
Christmas or summer the most expensive
and worse times to travel because
everybody's on vacation because you have
kids you own a Honda Odyssey you know
did you have one the poster of one of
those on your wall when you're a kid was
that your aspiration the Lamborghini in
the Honda Odyssey you've got one right
it's freaking hard work and they're
really annoying and then they have
problems and they're sick and they get
bad grades and who knows what so why
would anybody have a child it's for the
unpredictable glimmers when you catch
your five-year-old sharing with your
four-year-old
when you check to see that your kid is
sleeping you find them under the covers
with a flashlight reading the school
play the first girlfriend the first
boyfriend
it's the unpredictable glimmers that
make all of the sacrifice worth it and
the same goes here creativity is not
something that you get to have every day
if you did you'd be jaded and it get
boring thank you you know you don't get
that a living a creative life means that
you you accept the tedium and you accept
the the mundane as part of the process
of discovering the glimmers and when you
get those glimmers all the tedium
disappears it was all worth it you know
so there's no such thing as a thrill a
day and when people seek it out they die
young you know it's just not a
sustainable model asking for help helps
somewhat delegating helps somewhat
saying learning to say no to some things
helps somewhat but it's it's just it's
part of the deal
relationships are the same relationships
are really hard but it's the glimmers
when someone makes you feel like you're
the most special person on earth when
someone makes you feel that you're the
better version of yourself because
they're in your life you know you don't
get that every day you know and that
goes for friendships that goes for
really does anything like my III every
now and then I look at my I pull back
and I look at my own friendships and
it's not a criticism of the people that
are in my life that I call friends it's
a criticism of me which is I have people
my life that I can absolutely say with
absolute certainty that I'm a better
version of myself because they're in my
life
and if I lost them I would lose a piece
of me
there's without certainty without
without a doubt I mean with absolute
certainty and I also have people in my
life that if I look back at my
friendship
I really haven't grown at all because
they're in my life and I spend time with
them maybe because I don't like being
alone and they were available or I spend
time with them because they're funny and
I like him but if they disappeared would
I feel like a piece of me got lost
probably not and then I ask myself
because it's not a criticism of them
it's a criticism of me
I ask myself am i investing time and the
people that are helping me grow like
should I should I because if I never
called them they'd never call me I know
that too
you know so should I really have a few
nights alone in order to save up time
you know I don't have an answer for it
but these are the things I think about
so yeah
we'll do one more question one more one
more yes you've been waiting so
patiently and you're from the right side
of the game the one question from the
right side of the room one question for
resident there's a lot under shoulder
this better be a good question it's the
only question from the right side of the
room and it's the last question isn't
this exciting isn't this exciting just a
macro philosophical sense change is
happening so the question was in a world
of uncertainty how do we stay balanced
yeah
is that the question right I'll give you
the same answer I've given 15 times
today
you better have someone in your life who
loves you now the harder question is how
do you have someone in your life who
loves you
okay that's the harder question and
there's an answer to that too
you better be open to loving someone all
right that's all I got
[Music]